apple's m2 macbook air has been out for
over a week now and while it's a great
machine it's no doubt been causing a lot
of controversy and drama in terms of the
issues that it has like the ssd setup
and the thermal throttling and whether
those are a big deal and why apple would
make those decisions well we decided to
ask mark german who is the number one
apple leaker out there for his thoughts
on all of the drama who is right who is
wrong and some other details about
future macbook pros like the m2 pro and
max and whether you should wait for
those or not and other details as well
so let's jump right into our interview
mark german it is a pleasure to have you
on and you reached out on twitter we
spoke a little bit on twitter and you
mentioned if you could come on the show
and i'm like heck yes if you want to
come on the show for sure because as
everybody knows you are the most
reliable apple leaker you're basically
famous in the apple
tech space so uh how's it going good i
felt like we had to talk we had a lot to
talk about given the uh ssd stuff the
macbook air
uh the macbooks everything
going on lately
it uh seems like there's a little bit of
controversy around some topics
benchmarks and stuff right now and i
figured it'd be fun to talk about a
little bit of a reprieve for my day so
yeah good to talk and uh congrats to you
guys on uh i saw you have a million subs
now as of this week almost
uh almost
almost
either maybe maybe this video will put
you over the top who knows
hey let's do it yeah awesome yeah so
let's talk about that drama but i before
i get into like the m2 macbook air the
macbook pro
also talking about the future m2 pro m2
max 14 inch 16 inch other mac products
that we're expecting
and like three nanometer versus five
nanometer for those chips i do want to
start off just real cool
with a couple of questions of your
background and the main question i want
to ask is how did you start
and get into apple leaks i mean like
everybody wants to know that you know
how did you become so good
at apple leaks and so reliable so no no
i appreciate it so i started covering
apple around 2010 right when the first
ipad came out i worked for knights of
the mac was always super interested in
apple products and
everything going on with the company
followed very closely read all the sites
nine to five mac rumors etc that you
know are still around today there was
actually some
back then they're no longer around uh
unfortunately
um so played in that space for a while
worked at nine to five mac uh with the
crew there for i think six or seven
years
um
that was great and then i started at
bloomberg in 2016 um covering consumer
tech in apple so apple but also my
purview is a little broader than that so
i'll cover
some of the the consumer side of amazon
samsung
facebook i guess we call them meta now
and a few of the other interesting
companies so i have you know a lot of
flexibility with that uh everything
going on with bloomberg tv bloomberg
podcasts and quick take and i have my
power on column every weekend and such
which if anyone should subscribe to
bloomer.com
yeah so you know it's been a good time
um i love reporting on
what's next to come what's the next big
thing from apple but also not only the
next big thing the next small things as
well i like keeping people uh updated on
you know what's happening in in our
favorite company i mean at this point
apple
in terms of the attention it gets is
it's no different than the news maybe
coming out of a huge entity like you
know washington dc or the white house
and such right i mean everyone is
interested in what's the next iphone
going to look like what's the next ipad
going to have what will the next apple
watch be able to do what's the new
icloud sure that's going to be coming
out right what's new with the airpods
max and whatnot so yeah uh interest
level there is as high as ever and it's
uh pretty fun to you know contribute to
the community and have discussions with
people meet new folks and such and talk
to people like you and try to figure out
what's next uh for apple yeah
and i love doing that i love speculating
because like i'm not a leaker i mostly
just speculate i look at all the data i
try to figure things out
but you have sources you know yeah let's
go ahead and jump right into
the drama what are your thoughts on it
is it worth
talking about the drama like should
apple be held accountable uh before we
actually get into some of the details
like what are your thoughts on the drama
i mean if you're referring to sort of
the ssd thing that i think you were
forced to cover uh regarding
um so basically if i have this right the
entry level capacity ssds on the new
macbook pro macbook air with m2 they
have one ssd chip versus two split which
slows down some file transfers and other
things having to do with the ssd and as
you've shown some of your videos and
others have shown that could have an
impact on real world uh performance for
some people in some cases now your first
question was should apple be held uh
accountable should this information
published out there and how should
people respond to it i think of course
apple should be held accountable i think
of course these things should be
discussed and i think of course that
information should be out there and i
think what you should be proud of and
what others should be recognizing is if
it wasn't for people like you in your
channel and other people who discover
these things
consumers wouldn't have that information
because apple didn't disclose those
details in addition the review units
they provided were the higher capacity
review units now i don't think that
apple gave higher capacity review units
out uh in order to sort of hide that by
any means i don't think apple was doing
anything disingenuous with that uh based
on my experience apple traditionally
does give out the highest capacity
whatever color you want the top config
in most cases uh for review units and
these they've also done that so i don't
think apple was hiding anything
um i would say that apple probably
should have put some disclosure uh on
the online store page
or they should have put some sort of
bullet point in the legal print at the
very bottom of the macbook air macbook
pro page uh saying that you might get
even faster performance if you pick a
512 up configuration obviously they're
not going to say if you pick the 256
it's going to be slower they would say
and i think that's right and fair if you
pick this configuration up you will get
faster performance just like they
disclose on the tech specs page for the
ipad pro m1 that if you get the higher
capacity ipad pros you will be getting i
believe it's eight gigabytes of ram
instead of six right so i think there
was sort of a fair way to put that in
the copy on the website i don't think
it's something that should have
necessarily been mentioned at the event
um my pet peeve
or with the people who say that this
doesn't matter and apple shouldn't
disclose anything
i think that
consumers when they're purchasing these
machines they should have as much detail
uh as possible right in order to make
their purchasing decisions um obviously
these you know are low end on the max
spectrum but you know twelve hundred
dollars to eighteen hundred dollars or
north of that uh for a machine that you
might be holding on to for three or four
years i think these are important
purchasing decisions
a family member of mine did purchase a
new macbook air
uh uh when to come out last week
and i pushed them to get the higher
configuration model after seeing um you
know a lot of the discussion about the
base model it's just for you know you're
already spending a thousand plus i think
a 200 300 difference is not much more to
pay
uh if you're gonna hold on to that
machine for a while so i think consumers
having that information at hand i think
is important and i
like you guys i always strive to put as
much information out there
because consumers are smart and they're
knowledgeable people they they want as
much information as possible to
influence their purchasing decisions and
know what they should be doing with
their hard-earned cash uh so
that's that i think there's a lot of
people who've been pushing back uh on
geekbench and benchmarking software as
well recently
my take on that what you sometimes see
is you see if the if the benchmarks show
apple in a positive light you should
definitely try
if they show apple in a negative light
oh no no these benchmarks are are crap
they they are not to be trusted right so
i think what's important is the
information gets you put out there and
people can make whatever decisions they
want
um taking a public stance in either
direction probably not the best approach
just put the info out and let people
make those uh decisions yeah thank you
for that yeah uh one point that luke
miyani i don't know if you've watched
any of his videos um
he uh put out recently on the genius bar
podcast was that like for youtube for
example you know most of the regular
consumers they just go to the apple
store they buy whatever they see you
know but like the small portion that
actually care they're the ones that go
research and that's when like for them
it really matters to know these issues
you know and i would i really hate for
somebody to go out by the base model and
then they're doing multitasking and
they're wondering like hey why is this
seem slow why am i getting laggy you
know web browsing or whatever so that's
a very good point on the ssd and i agree
that apple like should have disclosed
something
you know that you know the ssd can
impact performance because in the past
like we would never see a difference
where you spend two to four hundred
dollars on ssd and ram and you could
like literally double the performance of
a test just like that so it's very
interesting but there are
some more issues i wanted to ask you
about and like how cool
i don't think it's a mass real world
issue
for 90 percent of people
i just think that that data should be
out there for that 10
where it may have an impact and perhaps
apple realized that most people won't be
impacted
so they didn't say anything right but
that doesn't mean that that information
isn't valuable thank you that's a very
good point another thing i wanted to ask
you about was
the whole thermal throttling situation
with the macbook air what are your
thoughts on that yeah i've uh i've been
using this unit um
considerably i spent a good amount of
time with it just so you know i'm
familiar with whatever latest and
greatest was i think it's awesome
i miss the taper edges a lot i think
it's super thin though
and really nice to hold it feels like
i'm on a 16 inch uh m1 max macbook pro
this feels like a shrunken down version
of that when apple does the 15-inch
macbook air in this form factor next
year i think that's going to be a really
nice machine
i don't know you know about the fan
situation on that i do think you know
they call it active cooling it's a fan
fine
it doesn't matter
you know i think it's important um for
people to know that this thing can slow
down depending on what you're doing you
know after a matter of several minutes
whereas you don't necessarily get that
impact on these macbook pros i have not
had a slow down
fans going off sluggishness once that i
could actively feel overheating on this
machine
that's probably not the case for a lot
of tasks on the macbook air
uh so i think it's definitely something
consumers should be aware of if you're a
student you're doing like web browsing
word work and whatnot i think you're
going to be fine on the macbook air
which is a case
instead of apple saying that this
machine doesn't have a fan you might
have these slow down issues they go in
the opposite direction which is macbook
pro has this active cooling system
that's the same performance now
if i put myself in the shoes of apple's
marketers of course that's what i'm
gonna do of course that's what you would
do that's what any you know
knowledgeable person with you know any
business background is going to do so
you know i'm not faulting apple on that
uh at all but it is important for
consumers to you know recognize the
differences and you know i don't know
you know someone should make a chart
about
what the penetration of apple stores and
best buys and stores where you can play
with these machines in person are in the
united states and globally right i
wonder what percentage of the u.s
population is within 10 miles from an
apple store or best buy where you can
try these out but i do think it's a good
thing that apple has 250 stores or
actually it's i think it's 270 or 71
stores in the u.s at this point probably
hundreds of more best buys where you can
maybe play with your workflow a little
bit to see if that machine is a fit for
you
uh for me personally based on my usage
of it it's not for me and i don't think
it's for you know most or i'll take that
back maybe it's for most people but this
way it's not for most people that i know
and work with right like it's a fit for
your you know video editing rig and you
know everything that you might be doing
and you know others in the space might
be doing uh for me it's not a fit with
my thousand chrome tabs i'm exaggerating
uh open at once for my family member who
is
using the machine
right which i maybe in this case is
probably representative of most people
uh i think it's a perfect that's a very
good point yeah i think for like light
usage a lot of web browsing a little bit
of light productivity i think it's also
a great machine especially the new um
the new design but one thing that i
noticed i don't know if you watched the
tear downs of this macbook air
or not did you by any chance
well i did not watch the teardown videos
uh of the macbook air talking about the
ifixit one but i read some summaries and
saw some photos and such of uh the
insides of the new one yeah one thing
that's very interesting is that uh
people actually compared the cooling
solution that came on the m1 macbook air
to this new m2 and the interesting part
is that they actually had like a block
heatsink on the m1
and on this m2 they just have like this
thin metal shielding without like a
actual proper heat sink
so um like that's kind of like
disappointing at least in my perspective
because if you watch the teardown
there's like this entire section on the
left side which is like almost empty and
it's like why didn't they use up that
space um
i don't know if you have any thoughts on
like the heatsink situation i would
guess that they thought the m2 could be
a bit more efficient than the m1 and
maybe not generate much heat in terms of
the heat sink and the changes there my
guess
would be that that contributes to making
the machine lighter and potentially
thinner being able to you know make that
change in the engineering there and i
think the goal for this product was in
order to you know thin it down a little
bit right get it a little bit lighter i
think they shaved off a couple tenths of
a pound and i think
um it's slightly thinner overall when
you don't factor in the tapers of the
previous model for that product i think
they just wanted to go as light thin and
light as possible
um what i think they ultimately probably
should do
is they
may want to come out with a cheaper
configuration of the 14-inch macbook pro
and get rid of that 13-inch macbook pro
in the middle with the touch bar and
that old design
um i think that a 14-inch macbook pro
maybe the 1499 or 15.99 price point uh
that sits between the air macbook pro uh
i think that would do pretty well and
that would be a pretty good machine for
a lot of people
you keep that at m2 chip rather than the
m2 pro m2 max you put the fan in there
and you have that new design you charge
100 more for it uh i think that would be
an excellent direction and then you have
sort of the 15-inch uh macbook air below
that my i do hope for the 15-inch
product that they do have sort of a more
m1 like heatsink and maybe some sort of
active cooling solution uh especially if
there are true that there'll be an m2
pro version of the 15 inch macbook air
and all things i don't believe that i i
don't see how they can put an m2 pro uh
inside a 15 inch macbook air unless
there are some change improvements to
the uh internals in order to provide
better sustained performance and less
issues related to heat nice and do you
think that lower end 14 inch
might come as soon as the m3 model like
when do you think that could possibly
come like the replacement for the
13-inch macbook pro yeah to be clear i
haven't heard anything about this uh
14-inch macbook pro being in the works
um it's something that i i just was
speculating off the cuff of you know
what they should do to sort of solve
this issue
and that gap there
i have not heard of that specifically uh
what i have heard is that there will be
new this is no shock to anyone there
will be new 14 inch and 16 inch high-end
macbook pros uh given the lockdown
situation the chip shortage and all the
other uh circumstances that apple's
dealing with right now i don't have an
exact launch
their plan
is and has been to launch them this fall
around october november
same designs but they would have the m2
pro m2 max
chips in both the 14 inch and 16 inch
units
um i'm sort of giving window of between
late fall and spring in order to sort of
factor in possible supply chain issues
but those machines are
engineering-wise those are basically
done so those will hit
the 15-inch macbook air
with the current 13-inch design but
bigger
that's supposed to come between spring
and summer
of 2023 so next year okay that's the m2
line still
uh and
in you know keeping it moving in terms
of future macbooks there's also a new
12-inch uh macbook in the works i
personally there is
right i've written about that in the
past i do think that will be an inch
macbook pro sort of to harken back to
the 12-inch power book they had from a
long time ago uh that probably not going
to come before 2024
and that's likely to be uh an m3 lineup
the m2 chip is basically a stop gap chip
um yeah if you think about how long i
think well
if you've said that too that is accurate
the whole idea of the m2 is that it's a
stop gap chip what i think people don't
know is that the underlying architecture
of the m1 and is a year behind
the underlying architecture of the a
series chips and the m2 is a year behind
as well and so they're going to need to
catch up at some point to bring
the a series and the m series to the
same underlying architecture and so the
m1 is based a14 the m2 is based on
the
a15
uh the m3s based on the a16 so these m2
chips we have today that's based on the
same architecture as what you have in
the iphone 13
right and so
the m3
will be the same architecture you're
getting with the a uh 16 for the iphone
13 pros this year and so perhaps 20 20
23 when you start seeing those same m3
chips
right you know then that's when you're
really going to be catching up with the
iphone 14
and then maybe at some point they change
the underlying architecture maybe with
the m4 and get exactly in the same
line there as a series chips so a lot to
be done there but yeah if you think
about how long the m1 lasted as a chip
first m1 machines came out november 2020
uh november 2020 you're still going to
see m1 machines or
max with the m1
so the newest mac in a particular
product line with an m1
being placed
into 2023. so the m1 is going to last a
long time whereas i think the m2 is
going to have a much shorter life span
as the new
chip uh in a particular unit for
instance the imac the imac is skipping
m2 altogether and that's going to be so
it is nice next year yeah whereas the m2
obviously you'll see m2 variations of
the macbook pro and sort of their higher
volume machines the imac for all
intensive purposes is no longer a super
high volume uh product now i have some
thoughts on what you said about the
whole um a16 chip and everything i kind
of had some speculation of
um because the
the iphone chips the a a series chips
come every single year but it seems like
the m chips are more on like a 18-month
kind of cycle eventually they're going
to have to skip something right
so my thought is what if
i don't know about your thoughts on this
but what if
the m2 pro and the m2 max as well as the
m3
they skip straight to three nanometer
which is gonna match the a17 in my
opinion which the a17 will also be three
nanometer what do you think about that
or do you think maybe three nanometer
could come sooner or what are your
thoughts because a lot of people say
it's going to be five nanometer for sure
for the m2 pro m2 max but i disagree
yeah i don't see given everything going
on with tsmc right and they're a little
behind samsung and some of the other
fabs when it comes to three nanometer
tech
um i don't necessarily see how they
would be able to get three nanometer in
um the max this year i think that's
probably a next year thing the iphone 14
pro and pro max as we know those are
going to be five what they call five
plus right or some variation some
sort of
version i think
something like that yeah an upgraded
variation of five millimeter
um what's also fascinating to me is that
for the first time since apple started
making its own chips for the phone um
base iphone 14 and the iphone 14 max the
non pros those are not going to get the
a16 those are going to be stuck on the
a15 right and i believe that's going to
be long-term differentiation between the
pros and non-pros on the phones just
like on the mac you're having regular m2
regular m3 et cetera versus pro and pro
max
variations with those chips oh
you know i think that's going to be
fascinating
what do you think about the macbook air
because right now we still have the m1
macbook air for a thousand and we have
the m2 macbook air for 1200 do you think
it's possible that when the m3
comes out what if they take the m2 chip
and also like keep the m2 as the
baseline either in the old design
or
i don't know what are your thoughts on
that i think that they
as new generations come out they will
retain the previous generation and bring
that down in price so once the m3
macbook airs come out and that's
probably two years away
um i would say yeah of course it's two
years away from now maybe a year and a
half but i think closer to two years if
not longer
they will
replace that thousand dollar
um m1 macbook air
with the one thousand dollar m2 macbook
air the one that exists today right and
the plan that was planned the plan was
always for this m2 macbook air to come
in at 200 higher than the macbook air m1
and to retain that macbook air one at
that thousand dollar price point so the
m2 today
two years from now 200 price drop nice
so i wanted to ask about the m2 and m2
m2 pro and m2 max 14 and 16 inch do you
know of any potential features
any kind of exclusive feature
differences you might know like
potentially face id
can we expect that or do we wait longer
what do you think so there won't be any
face id this year uh they've worked
they've worked on it the problem with
face id is the thickness of the display
i think if you see face id appear on a
mac it will appear in the imac first
uh i personally do think that touch id
is probably uh the most convenient at
this point uh on a keyboard
more convenient than having facetime uh
or face id in the display i'm they would
have a user experience problem to figure
out how people know they're logging into
a computer just with their face what
would you click to get through obviously
that's a software and your problem is
pretty easy to solve the hard part is
the technical challenge of getting in
that thin screen they should be able to
do it technology wise in a more
expensive imac because of that component
cost i would doubt it would be on the
very low end um but i don't anticipate
face id appearing on a macbook or
anything like that any time at all in
the near future that's probably
uh technology-wise
and in terms of the m20 m2 max
i don't have the core counts in front of
me
but if you look back and see what i've
reported it's going to be that i think
right now
it's a 10 core
cpu and a 32 core gpu right i believe
and you'll have to double check my
stories i believe they're moving to a 12
core cpu
and they're moving to i think it's a 38
or 40 core gpu so you're going to see uh
increases on both the cpu speeds uh and
the gpu core counts and overall speeds
as well
uh i think if you're on an m1 pro or m1
max machine today i'm not sure you're
going to want to necessarily run out and
swap out just for the increased counts
these are going to be spec bumps as
we've seen on the iphone and the ipad
you rarely see a spec bump only on those
devices the more highly volume devices i
think on the mac what we're used to as
consumers over the last 20 years plus is
that they do refresh the machines
annually right or every year and a half
eight months
with an upgraded processor without any
more fundamental changes to the product
and i think that's what you're gonna see
uh with this m2 version thank you yeah i
actually agree with that i think they'll
most likely just swap out the chip and
as far as other changes probably they
won't now i did want to ask you about
another mac
or with like
would be on par with the transition from
the m1 13-inch pro to the m2 13-inch pro
where i think it was you or other people
they opened that thing up and it's
identical other than the chip swaps i
think someone also tried putting the m1
chip
in the m2 macro was that you look luke
miani
him yeah and that didn't work i thought
that was interesting i'm not surprised
it didn't work but i did think that was
funny um
yeah anyways
now i did want to ask you about another
mac mini which i personally based on
apple's filings of the eec
numbers and different model numbers that
we got with the m2 air
and um whatever else do you think we
could potentially see the redesigned m2
mac mini this fall yeah i don't think
there will be a redesign to the mac mini
i actually don't know where the rumors
of a redesign came from i think those
are also going to be spec bumps if you
look at the mac studio the mac studio
looks like a double height mac uh mac
mini it would be really weird to just
come out with this mac studio and then
you have a mac mini the smaller
variation of the mac studio
um basically coming in with a new design
that would be odd to me the mac studio
is basically a mac mini pro right
they're just calling it the mouse
the mac mini you'll see an m2 version as
well as an m2 pro version because right
now you have an m1 version of the mac
mini i also believe they sell an intel
variation of the mac mini is that right
or they used to i think you need to
right so you need a replacement for that
performance and that's why you're going
to see the m2 mac mini and the m2 pro
mac mini what i had heard was that there
are three mac mini's planned for 2022
the three being the m2 mac mini the m2
pro mac mini and then the mac studio
okay so that would mean they would come
probably this fall and you'd have the
option of the m2 or the m2 pro
in the same mac yeah they also had an m1
mac pro
uh ready to go months ago they did but i
guess they scrapped that just wait for
the m2 pro version okay so what are your
thoughts do you think it's going to come
this year potentially if they release it
in december with the whole m2 pro based
quad ship or do you think they're going
to wait till next year because i believe
ming cha quo thinks it's waiting till
next year
mac mini or the mac pro the mac pro the
mac pro mac pro i think that will be
announced uh
end of year they were going to announce
it uwdc but that didn't happen i think
they're going to announce it end of year
and then release it next year in 2023
and then there'll be an imac pro at some
point as well that's been in in active
development so that will be sometime
next year maybe the year after so those
both are coming
i think they're going to call the chip
and the mac pro the m2 extreme so what
that is is it's the m2 ultra so the m1
ultra but the m2 variation right mac pro
just like the m the mac studio the bass
is the is the max and the high end is
the ultra then the mac pro the base is
the ultra and the high end is the 2x
ultra and i really don't think there's
anything else you can call it other than
m2 extreme extreme that's a good name so
you think they might announce it this
year and maybe january they'll release
it uh i don't think it'll be released in
january no oh okay so there's springtime
probably if not a little later maybe
summer um maybe they even get announced
this year there is so much on their
plate to announce right now and chip
right now and the problem they're facing
is the allocation of resources for both
production of the actual hardware and
equipment
combined with inflation and pricing and
everything going on there plus uh
circumstances around the chip shortage
right so needing to elevate which chips
go where
uh which process nodes they're using for
which products and where they're
allocating their resources now
you know number one priority the first
thing they have to do is make sure they
have enough chips for the phones and the
a16 chips for the phones remember this
is fab tsmc doing all of apple's trips
across the product family at this point
and so i don't think anything of
significance happens until they have
full
uh understanding and full ability to pop
out as many a16s as they need do you
think there's a chance that they can
switch from like in the past they used
to design the a series chip and then
they'd kind of
soup it up to the ax in the ipad pros do
you think there's a chance they could
switch to do the reverse where they do
the highest and you know let's say the
m2 max first and then kind of take that
and then shrink it down
to the a17 for example i don't think so
i think from an engineering perspective
it really has to be done the other way
because you need that core architecture
in place
and the m1 chip is the a14 chip from
i believe that would be the iphone 12
right it's the iphone 12 z14 chip with
additional cpu cores and additional gpu
cores plus some of the advanced media
encoders and and whatnot some of the
extra bells and whistles you need for a
math-based processor uh also the
expanded neural engine uh as well yeah
so uh what about other products this
fall like potentially what do you think
about the ipad 10 do you think it's
getting the full usbc redesign or no
what are your thoughts on that uh the
ipad 10 if you're referring to the 10th
generation base ipad yep the the budget
yeah base ipad yeah and it should look
the same as the current one but have
usbc uh as well as the i believe it's
the a14 i don't have my notes in front
of me but it should be the a14 and usbc
and so at the end of this year all
new ipads will be usbc
next year you'll see the usbc transition
uh continue on to the iphone and so the
iphone 15 that line that will be usbc
as well what about the airpods pro 2 i
did see a report recently where the
airpods pro could actually switch to
usbc this year
like before the iphone 15 switches do
you think that makes sense or i'm not
sure i i honestly don't answer to that
question but it makes a tremendous
amount of sense to me given the timeline
that the airpods pro is on it seems like
it's a two
let's see i'm trying to remember it's a
three year upgrade cycle right so the
2019
2019 is when the initial airpods pro
launched right and so the next one will
come out around three years at the end
of 2022 uh and so if those are going to
be in the marketplace for two to three
years it would make sense uh to move
that to usbc for this generation and i
think
yeah it would be a very strong hint for
that to happen on the iphone next year
as well
um
i do think three years is too long maybe
for that upgrade cycle for the airpods
pro because you know samsung is cutting
out their new earbuds pros next year i
think that's a one or two year upgrade
cycle so you know maybe apple should
step up step on the gas uh a little bit
uh on those i have the air pods max uh
and gray like you have i think they look
really ridiculous on me this is why i'm
not wearing them
i think the case is tremendously bad
uh i think those uh airpods max probably
need a little bit of an upgrade i also
don't think they sound as good as their
price might uh you know
yes and what some people may think of
them
uh definitely think that they're
comfortable and they obviously have a
nice design
so there's definitely utility there
i think the market has shown that people
are unwilling to pay the full 550 for
them that's why you've seen so many
discounts
i saw a sky blue pair on b h photo.com
um yesterday at four
uh
439 so 440 right and i think that 400
450 price point is probably about the
sweet spot for those so i'm not entirely
sure how upland on the 550. do you think
there's a chance with the airpods max 2
or whatever i don't know when they're
coming out but do you think there's a
chance apple could lower the price point
or they're just going to keep the same
just your own speculation uh this would
just be pure speculation i would say
maybe they'll you know knock them down
to 4.99 throw some new colors usbc on
them um you tell me what what do you
think's missing from the airpods max at
this point future set wise i mean i
think first of all uh
lossless audio support because they
don't support lossless and of course the
usbc other than that they're pretty good
i did want to ask you about the lossless
do you have any info on that potentially
for the airpods pro 2 or for these macs
and when we could expect it uh i think
there will be some lossless like
functionality on the airpods pro 2. i'm
not entirely sure there are definitely
new airpods max uh headphones in the
works um i don't know when those are
coming at this point they were supposed
to come this year
with new colors so sort of like a color
refresh just like you get like the band
color refreshes on the apple watch so it
might be next year potentially
i think it'll be this year
oh okay
uh but i don't know for sure in uh the
last thing i wanted to ask you another
product which we've been talking about a
little bit is the apple watch
um because i know like you know there's
the whole rugged thing it's just so
confusing with everything that happened
because we thought the series 7 would be
like this new redesign but it ended up
you know being a little bit more curvy
so what are your thoughts is there a
chance that the one that's coming this
year specifically the new you know pro
model that we might get that's going to
be more expensive do you think it's
going to be redesigned with like a more
flat design or what are your thoughts on
that i will let my power on newsletter
this week and answer that question so
okay if you uh tune into that if the
video goes live after that's out
head to uh
your email if you're not subscribed or
boomer.com or my twitter but that is a
good question and
definitely uh yeah something that i know
a lot of people have been asking me
about that's exciting what about any of
the other features um
that you might think could be coming in
terms maybe like the material or
anything else and if it's gonna like
start at a very high price
um like i like i personally think
they're like there's a perfect spot for
a pro model because like you know when
people are to pay more they want it to
say pro in my opinion you know um i
think it'll be called the apple watch
pro and i think it'll be between 100 and
a thousand dollars i think it's going to
be a very high-end apple watch with more
battery life with a bigger display um
with more durability right and i think
that is going to
uh it's not going to be the most popular
apple watch given the price point but i
think it's something that would
certainly be interesting to the consumer
that's willing to spend the money on an
iphone 13 pro max or a 16 macbook pro
right it's for the uh the ultimate apple
consumer i think you can say and it's
interesting that they've really you know
went full throttle on this standard risk
pro
uh strategy where they're delineating
some of the products in their lineup
and so you know i'm very fascinated to
see uh you know how they launch it in
september and uh final thoughts uh you
did break a report recently about apple
like slowing hiring and uh slowing
spending like do you have any details on
that and like what's going on in the
whole space
i don't know if you want to talk about
potential recessionary stuff or
sure i mean you know many economists out
there the stock market
the fluctuating u.s dollar uh higher
interest rates obviously rising
inflation the gas price situation that
we all know about you know clearly there
is some sort of economic downturn or
recessionary recession or recession like
event looming
right and so
apple and the cfo's office what they're
trying to do is sort of anticipate how
they can keep the company
in the most good standing as possible
through a situation like that and what
does that mean it means perhaps not
hiring as quickly as they would like to
not spending as much money on
human-based capital r d
as they would like to perhaps that means
not backfilling roles as much as what
they would like to uh in some divisions
right i don't anticipate that negative
uh you know hit and process hitting some
of their more you know important areas
such as future products whether that's
the mixed reality headset the electric
car
but i would be shocked if they didn't
scale down some hiring and spending on
some pretty mature units in the company
like perhaps the iphone the ipad uh
maybe the apple watch right but i think
the hotter areas of growth ai cloud
services car ar vr
um mr whatever you want to call it i
think that is going to continue and do
you think any of the products that we're
seeing this year like maybe even the m2
macbooks in like the future iphones do
you think those were impacted
by like the whole situation potential
recession do you think they've changed
those already and their plans for those
in anticipation of a slowdown to like
cut costs
higher profit margins what do you think
on that i would say that regarding the
macbook
m2 and the macbook air the impact there
from covid and some of the economic
situations we've seen
that
had to do with the shipment the shipping
time frame
so this mac air
launched
i would say let's see
six to nine months later than it was
supposed to
right i think that was driven primarily
by covid and allocation of resources in
terms of recessionary stuff economics
um i think that factors a little bit
into the iphone 14. now the chip
shortage is twofold the one part of the
chip shorter that everyone talks about
is it make being harder to get chips
right that no that's very obvious part
two of the chip shortage is the
inflation aspect for it the cost aspect
freight and shipping and the allocation
resources right and so i think a
decision had to be made to sort of split
the iphone 14 between a15 models and a16
models versus the basic versus the pro
and i think the chip shortage and
combined with the costs that go into
being able to get those chips factored
in so i think that the decision was
do we want to make the base iphone 14s
more expensive and include the a16
because the a16 today is more expensive
to make than it may have been three
years ago because of everything
economically plus the chip short right
or do we retain the a15 and keep the
price the same what is going to do
better for sales and what do consumers
care more about and i think they made
the correct decision if those were
indeed the two decisions to make i think
they made the correct decision whereas
the buyer of a base iphone 14 or i4
iphone 14 max they are more concerned
with how much they pay for it reverse
the performance differences between the
a15 and a16 or someone who might be
spending more money on an iphone 14 pro
or iphone 14 pro max they are more
concerned with the performance of the
product and the upgrade on the chip
rather than the price pressure yeah
thank you i agree with that and um
do you think there's gonna be a price
increase for the pro models i don't know
perhaps maybe they'll play around with
pricing a little differently on storage
capacities i personally would be would
not be surprised either way if right
like the iphone 14 max came in at you
know 8.99 right or 9.99 and they made
the pro models a little bit more
expensive so i don't know the answer to
that question
uh but i think what we've seen from
apple given the products they've already
launched in 2022 i don't think we've
seen
um
price increases or price changes that
are out of scope from what had already
been planned uh
or
inflationary pressures we're seeing
right i think apple realizes it would be
a mistake to start hiking prices on top
of everything else going on yeah because
if they hike prices and then people are
more like you know thinking about budget
it could lead to lower sales uh what do
you think about like the base storage of
the iphone do you think it's going to
stick around to 128 for another year or
maybe like the ipad pro when do you
think those will go to 256. oof probably
not for a little while especially giving
the chip shortage and everything else
going on and the freight costs that
might go into shipping chips and making
a ship like that uh yeah i would say
they're gonna stick to 128 on the base
um at least for the non-pros right um
it's funny so i have the 256 gigabyte
and i was thinking about like which
storage capacity i would get uh for for
this year i think i maybe get the maybe
look at the 512. the interesting thing
to me is that
you know an important thing to me
is the value that these devices hold and
being able to resell them
so if you have a 256 gigabyte iphone if
you have a one terabyte iphone um
they have a one terabyte iphone right
i think they do i think so
right um
those are work the same on the
marketplace
right if you're going to resell them to
your carrier or to apple and you know
ebay and such right the storage doesn't
have a big factor there so i think you
can offload some things in the cloud and
make it work and such so
i try to go with the lower storage
capacity that i can get away with
awesome well thanks for answering those
questions i just want to know like do
you plan to work at bloomberg for i
don't know if you can answer that or not
you know for
longer like stay in the apple space
leaking apple stuff for long term yeah i
think i'll be in the apple space for the
foreseeable future obviously the future
is long
and you know i have a lot of you know
plans for the future and such
um but you know as of right now i don't
see myself going anywhere
anytime soon i think it's definitely
exciting to to cover apple and to write
about products and have conversations
like this
so yeah i couldn't be happier to do it
uh obviously you know when you do
something for so long so at this point
i've been
in this space for 12 years or so
uh you know sometimes it could feel like
it's getting long in the tooth or it
could feel like you know maybe i should
try something different but what i've
been able to do is sort of expand to you
know talking about other companies from
time to time uh whether it's like i
mentioned amazon and whatnot
also as apple increases its areas of
interest there thereby creates new areas
of interest for me ar vr car ai etc
and the other thing is being able to
tell interesting stories in new ways
such as being able to go on bloomberg tv
uh being able to hop on podcasts being
able to hop on shows like yourself
my power on column as well has been a
big you know energy boost for me too
so i definitely think that you know yeah
this should continue for
you know the foreseeable future you
think i should continue
i definitely think so man like you give
us a lot a lot of awesome leaks awesome
sources and that obviously provides us
with like content to make and also like
stuff to speculate on and i mean you're
like the king of chip leaks with all the
core counts it's like i don't even know
how you get that but it's right like all
the time put it this way i'm happy to
give you and your channel and a few
other channels you know things to talk
about
uh there are a few channels and a few
people on twitter that i'm not so
you know happy to give material for them
to talk about and monetize and such but
you know i guess it's the nature of the
beast hey man well i appreciate it it's
been an honor having you on you know we
don't do this kind of stuff no podcast
stuff but for you you know make it up
exception and it's been awesome to have
you i really appreciate it uh any final
thoughts or if you want to make a shout
out for people uh yeah if you haven't
checked out the newsletter it's
bloomberg.com poweron
i'm on twitter at mark german uh should
have some more exciting scoops and
stories out in the coming days and you
know
i guess hopefully for the foreseeable
future like i said so please stay uh
tuned for that
and congrats to you and your channel you
guys on the uh all the success so far
and hope to do this soon awesome thank
you margaret thank you sir